me and my friends at gamespot have  always wanted to be basketball video  game people so thanks a good folks at  NBA 2k15 I was now possible down anyway  right I'm gonna be a superstar you know  in the future this is how ok cupid is  going to work my face you get a salt and  pepper you do the hair separate though  makes it fall making sure that makes you  bald automatically you add your hair it  references like your nose or chin I  think I'm not very defined face so this  is it covering me never look a lot of  points over there as long as not  something my face featured video games  is terrible all right there you go to me  nailed it  with the 16th pick in the 2014 NBA draft  the San Antonio Spurs select Jeremy  brown from Oklahoma ah this guy and he's  terrible